okay this is a candy crush soda saga
level 19 walkthrough tutorial
with some commentary to explain how to
beat this level
it's a bubble level where you have to
get the bear and the bubble above the
candy string
and um it spans several boards so it's
pretty tough
the main thing you want to do is move
the bear up as fast as you can
you know you have lots of chances to
make
matches down here with different you
might want to make some special candies
but as you'll see once you
move the bear up that board disappears
anyways so it's really not that
important i mean there's times when you
can get them float back up when they're
on the lower board but
if you have a way to move forward you
should always try to do that first
and um you can see the soda level ends
here
so some bottles are going to start
coming onto the board
shortly so this is a good example of a
good move um
you're going to make a match above the
bear with the blue that's going to go up
and you're also going to set up
a nice um color bomb notch
and luckily it still fits on the board
there so we can do that
it wouldn't be a bad idea to if you
couldn't match this green it wouldn't be
a bad idea to
use the color bomb on the green just to
get that match really quickly but
since we have a match and one that we
can make a fish with we'll just go ahead
and do that first
in these types of levels fish are
actually really useful because they'll
um
they'll eat the bottles and raise the
level of the soda faster
so we're going to use this one in one
second but we
have a yellow one that we can drop down
and and make this bottle
um pop first so we'll do that
that also made us another special candy
we lost our green
match for the fish but that's okay
we're just going to keep popping the
bottles and moving the side up and see
how the board changes you see i'm just
continuing to make fish when i can
continue up bottles when i came and now
i can
pop the bottle and get this fish because
we have these trapped in the
in the licorice and the fish will help
that
tremendously
i'm gonna go ahead and make this rap
candy match first and then do this
because since these candies are outside
of the
soda they don't the matches with those
don't affect
the ones that are below so i'm gonna
make another color bomb here
i'm gonna go ahead and free this first
though
make another color bomb it'll get fired
off
all right so this is where it gets a
little bit trickier but since we
did a pretty good job of um
making special candies along the way
shouldn't have too much trouble here
just looking around real quick to see if
i can make any more fish before i make
the match
and i don't see a spot to do that so now
i'm gonna just i'm gonna go with the
striped
um since we don't have anything to break
instead what we're trying to do is free
up all these
which the bombs the wrapped won't do we
definitely want to go with the stripe
here
because this might free up our extra
bottles so that we can raise the level
and now we're really close here um
but matching this yellow won't actually
bring it across the line because the
soda has to go up one more level
so all you got to do at this point is
just get a fish it'll eat this bottle
over here
raise the level one time
and now you can
save your bear so it's a pretty tough
level when you first play it especially
when you're not
used to these um new
get the bear above the candy string
levels um but that's
those are the basic the fundamentals
that you need to know to get past it you
want to move the bear quickly
and um you know pick up make fish
to attack the bottles and um make some
special candies along the way so that
you can get right to the top
if you have any questions leave a
comment um
please like the video if you found it
helpful and
we have other videos like this so make
sure you check out our site candy crush
sodasagatips.com
thanks